man i was in nashville this weekend uh
for shows or just looking around just
looking around
and thoughts great city great we saw
something we love
there's only a few places where if
you're gonna leave california
it's nevada mm-hmm arizona
texas and nashville outside that you're
really especially for what we're doing
that's what i'm saying yeah
you're in the business the biz yeah
those are really the only
right and you want to save money because
i don't want to go to new york
can't go to new york i can could you do
one of those winners
oh absolutely not meaning i'm from
denver dude i can't do it
i couldn't talk about no i couldn't do
it a boston winner no man a denver
winner
and you know what's funny is people
always say but you're from us jews
i'm like yeah it was [ __ ] cold when i
lived there too yeah i learned my lesson
that's why i
never want to deal with that again
waking up in the morning scraping out my
window
was of the car the worst start to the
morning
ever do you know what we used to do as
kids though
because everybody would let their car
run in the morning we would go out
uh this dude this kid that uh uh i grew
up around and we would get in people's
cars and move them
so if you're you were warming up your
car in your driveway you moved down we
would get it we would move it and switch
it with your neighbor's car so you'd
come out and there would be a car
warming up in your driveway it just
wasn't yours it's hilarious
but the kids might hear would just steal
the car
so because i remember there was like uh
i think pioneer made it where you could
click a button because
it'd be freezing like a blizzard yeah
and you'd be in the house you could just
start your car so when the time you got
in everything was defrosted is warm
which you take like half an hour to warm
up but you could just press a button
well that word got around town then
people just jacking cars
dude it was the worst way to wake up
dude the scraping the windshield
i remember the i remember vividly the
last time i scraped the windshield i
said to my dad i put it down
and i said hey i'm never doing that
again the worst and he said i'm
i'm going to be living in cold weather
for a long time i go yeah but i'm
i'm out i'll never be back it's not
sports aren't fun sledding's all right
skiing snowboard overrated tell me how
much it sucks to be walking in your
kicks
and to step in one of those slush
puddles i don't know it was [ __ ]
yeah over dude no i like the fashion in
winter like coats but if it's too big
then you take it off you're sweaty
inside the other thing is you know how
you can tell it's too cold here's how
here's how i can tell you right now i'm
never living in your city
if i don't know my nose is running until
i taste it oh dude it's too [ __ ]
just too numb it's just numb if it rolls
down you're like
dude so but you guys went to nashville
and he loved it went to nashville man
we really really loved it and um
you know the truth is and i'm sure
you're going through this
also did you ever think you were going
to leave
l.a never so it's that's what it is for
me when
for me it's i'm not nervous starting
there and i'm
i actually that newness excites me me
too it gets my creative juices going
but as life-wise as a person
i i just always saw myself here do you
know insulin
the worst anxiety yeah yeah yeah and i'm
also worried about and it's one of the
current events is jerry seinfeld was
talking about new york because
this this blogger wrote how new york's
dead and jerry goes in on him
and i stand by everything jerry said and
he talks about how
you know there's a creativeness and
there's energy with new york and l.a and
tokyo and london and
i'm worried that that creativeness and
that energy
might be lost if you go you know like i
was talking to tim dillon
about moving to austin i'm like dude
let's go out there and start a
show podcast studios and stuff and he
goes
maybe because my my worry is it feels
like i'm actually moving into retirement
because it feels a little bit like
retirement if we move out there
which i understand a hundred percent i
want you know one of the reasons that
like when our kid my kids we were empty
nesters and we were still stuck out in
encino
i said to beth i'm like what the [ __ ] we
gotta get out
down into the energy because i'm
becoming complacent out here
i'm just i'm just sitting in my house
you know i'm just sitting here like
where's
you're the first person and i and i'm
sure other people feel this way but
you're the first person to put it
the same way i've been putting with
putting it which is that energy that you
can't
see it but you feel it you feel it as
soon as you touch down that lady can
feel it yeah you're ready and so i will
say
that it's scary right that's the thing
that scares me the most did you feel it
in nashville though there's a bit of a
buzz in nashville but so we're not going
to
move out to franklin or any of those
places out there
which is outside the city which is where
families are beth and i are we're not
going to be downtown and i don't want to
say exactly where we're going to be
but we're going to be in the mix a
little bit because that's what we want
we want that energy we want to be
where people are walking around we want
to be where someone can walk
to get their [ __ ] their groceries where
their people just moving all the time
you know what i mean see what i want oh
i kind of have it here where i live
far from the city so my home life it's
safe there's
yards there's kids can play there's wide
open areas but then i drive in
into the end yeah energy and the the
vibe of a big city and then i can get
out
because i don't want my family living in
the energy i'm i'm with you that man but
my kids are all i know you're good
you're grown so
that's the thing theo's going to
nashville just for the month of
september just to feel it out
and he's just waiting to see what
everyone does what do you feel like for
you
is that your biggest fear is what'll
happen creatively and outside of that
you're not scared
like you're good with all of it scares
me yeah
all that scares me yeah i think you know
it's like the
you know the bands breaking up man by
band i mean all of us
yeah you know freaking joey zoe
already in new jersey i'm a texas
morning joey's in new jersey
um you know other guys aren't working
for other reasons right we won't get
into brogan
is in texas uh do you feel like
it to me it's just like you know one
thing that
keeps me here in la is like my friends
might get that in even if
we might have saw each other all the
time but we would work with each other
and see each other at the store or with
improv or wherever
it's just like now that that's kind of
gone it's like i don't know man
here's here's the thing that i'm excited
about because
i am the type of person though where
something new and scary excites me
me too and i am the type of person that
needs that every now and then
i need to be like i don't know let's not
open the shoot for a while let's see
what the [ __ ] happens
me too i do better when i'm like i need
to figure this out me too it always
works out better for me too i'm like
[ __ ] when i'm a little scared i'm like i
don't know man then i dialed down
because right now
it's you know my stuff in
la is pretty set like i know you know
obviously there's
shenanigans firing the kid right but
outside that everything's pretty
i might have a schedule it's like
there's not too much unknown
here's the one thing i will say that i'm
excited about and for you guys who are
moving to austin also
so comedy in la got as good
as it could possibly get like best ever
without a doubt man if you if you
combine
the talent that was here like the amount
of when i
when i would go on the road i'm sure you
too and you would look at who was at the
club before you and who's after you
always do you're just like killer killer
kayla's dude killer killer killer
every club i'm like well you guys got
three months of just
monster heat yeah right so what was
happening here
was bound to we we all talked about it
i'm sure you did when's the bubble gonna
burst when the bubble went right
i think what's exciting is so
it got as good as it got and now let's
see what's next
yeah it's almost like i don't think it's
here though i don't either not right now
i don't either i think some of the
smaller places i don't i don't i don't
think so either i don't know
look when when um if you look at the
comedy store and we both love the comedy
store and the comedy store man
mitzi passed me i worked the door at the
comedy store i didn't know you were a
door guy
i worked the tour of the comedy store
what yeah dude mitzi your door who
were you a door guy with anyone else
that made it ah
cause for every door guy that's made it
there's way more that did it yes
but you're also a bouncer at a nightclub
like dude just because you're a door guy
doesn't give you any credit into the
like you know what missy said to me
the first time she catches me up coming
off stage and she gave me the you get
the bony finger
that sounds dirty but it is yeah but
she's calling you over and i sat down
next to her and she said um
you were very funny and i said thank you
and she goes you're so handsome like a
young steve guttenberg
stephen all right well and i was like
all right it's a weird reference but uh
but going back to nashville like i think
whether it's nashville texas phoenix
vegas it's different too if this was you
know in the 90s or 80s like when you're
gone it you're [ __ ] gone
now it's like with connecting internet
connect
podcast social media it's like you're
still connected
you know a hundred percent you're not
just off the map
and if you you can still have your boys
on your show they can fly there
they can zoom like it's not like just
josh is gone you know we're never gonna
hear from you like you can still be in
the same
orbit you had to be in
la or new york before and now that's
just not the case
it's just not the case and that's what
makes it less scary
it makes it like okay this is kind of
like
look we're not we're not pioneers we're
not going into cities that don't have
buildings
you know what i mean but we are going
into a place that doesn't exactly have
what we do
so there is a huge unknown but at the
end of the day
how many of the people who listen to
this show are in los angeles
yeah yeah yeah i know
what i mean like so if i think about the
money
that i actually make because i'm here
agree there's more pros than cons
especially the way this
the especially the way this states
headed dude i would
if i'm you with two young kids i would
love to raise them somewhere
no offense to the other parents where
you live in richie ridgeville but
i think i loved my kids growing up with
a little diversity
and a little roughness not rough
like danger but like yes yeah with a
little bit
because like dude even here we went on a
tour of other schools that he would go
to from
you know kindergarten through sixth
grade and we're going around the schools
i'm like jesus christ man
jesus christ what do you looks like a
goddamn apple
building it's like there's gonna be no
obstacles there's just
how many benefits did you get out of
growing up poor
but but even but and not only that but
growing up around so many different
people yeah
navigate my way through right just get
this kid's super hostile this kid's this
like you don't want it all to be a
smooth ride as much as i don't want to
deal with turmoil it's like you kind of
got him it
i think and also if you look at the
public schools especially that lake
travis
in certain public schools in austin
those public school systems some of the
best in the nation
because of barbara bush who was a former
teacher put all this funding into the
schools
so schools are through the [ __ ] roof
like there's something with that that i
dig
i and i am a i i'm a firm believer in
public schools man like i'm in la i'm
not cause
i do want my kid to survive like there
is you know
you wanted to have a bit of a rough time
but you also want to stay alive you but
you would yes
but you want to go to a school and be
like you don't want him growing up being
like everybody's rich and white
correct because we know those people
i've never enjoyed any of them
not a [ __ ] one of them not a [ __ ]
one of them so
i think it's really important man i
think you're doing the right thing
especially
for schools and by the way you know
what's going to be here in five years
california
that's what i saw my father-in-law
yesterday because he's gonna retire he's
gonna come with us and you know they
don't tax his 401k out there stuff like
that
and uh you know i was like i just have i
get horrible anxiety when i think about
like i love my house picture picking all
the stuff up and leaving the kids and
stuff like that
and he was running at the end of the day
let's say worst case scenario you go out
there
and you hate it what you're not but
let's say you [ __ ] hate it
you know they still here man you know
he's come back a year or two later like
it's not
for you're not going to another country
yeah you just come back
and dude you'll come back with a renewed
uh you know my thing is i'm not gonna
just
move to like like travis and just be
gone forever
right like i'm still gonna have to fly
back probably weekly to start to la me
too commute
i i mean i already i told beth i'm like
i'm probably gonna have to fly back
because but all your all your kids are
gonna still be here right
my kids are here my brothers are all
here all three of my brothers live here
um you know my parents live in reno and
i but i told my parents
i said if if i was a like my parents are
in their 80s
so they're taking zero risk and i don't
blame them they're like hey we
don't want to travel they don't travel
my dad hasn't left his house since
my dad too cnn ran one article look my
dad's
my dad and mom are both over 80. so as
healthy and my dad
goes he does golf every day does have
your genetics my dad has
had a six-pack at 65 years old your
dad's straight yeah he's fine
he's he's good this dude but they don't
want to leave
they don't take a chance but i get that
i totally get it so he told
my mom and dad both were like look if
you go to nashville and you're worried
about not seeing us
you're not going to see us till spring
anyway yeah it doesn't matter
dude my dad i told my dad like you guys
i sent a picture of boss he's like jesus
christ he's getting big
i sent him a video of tiger singing
because tiger loves music right now so i
sent him a video that's he singing
uh meet me in the middle yeah yeah
yeah i love drake he loves drake all
right but so i saw my dad a vid and he's
like god i miss him he's like
we're going to come out there i'm like
oh yeah the flights are cheap i'll book
your tickets like
chill nobody's flying yeah we'll drive
out there like god damn from colorado
yeah
he's like we'll just drive non-stop as
he just got i don't know dude we used to
go on road trips as a kid but that's
he's like we're not dealing with covet
at all okay all right when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song